like though he'd read this
please take your seats we will start in
some moments just you
Caligula and colleague in via Stockton
on John Hartigan
let's turn pronoun oxidizer mr. Cooper
Odom and thus far which can Spurs on
disaster begin destroyed in taargus and
France team amongst in executive its
president
the Commission on thorns burglaries and
often they gotta have executive it's a
president near France so that an enemy
in their noncommissioned must each tier
has reached Scrat or even an amazing
height parents to begin Dinah on site
psyched
the Sweden Green Deal reminds I'm a foul
on owns its own jet solution if installs
of the films for videographers Union B
cell by then when prima for Hanuman and
innominate after out Shuster a
humanistic I reached the next in vaca
burdens if sex on ceramic leader in the
eugenic at see on their cop filaments
vanish in Madrid I'm finding Indiana
3015 balance the outer sphere CEO
Institute see on the iron shield shrine
or a Lazaro puppy 3054 that rocked
before as you behind comment from Perry
synthesized it water the last ones of a
photo on the streets from Davi of these
unrest Fubini she still there our
patient ano infest Suzette's as this as
absolute minimum
Angus Escrima note standards are the
fragrance leash may have up via Afton
cream Evander the agiel Emerson missions
and on we unleash Nell local on
dragonology beads copper shaft miss
Indaba an issue for Vendetta sunlen
concerts leisure on mystic October and
partners on Eva France we haven't missed
Ferguson the student force it's the task
force of generated in the hottest
unleashed on KDF ones were Goethe Yasuda
Zog and have four hundred salmon abide
in dismal
the task force is students ruski common
dusty eine neue albeit slice about a big
event infiltrator of local oh and Reagan
Allah even better
I'm Sebastian we were in reminds I'm the
officiants we will come on 10 May
awareness arrests feel asleep in the
Berlin and Rogoff focus on the Green
Deal betadine a GU Tagalog in height
p.m. film and the task falls in the
Praxis on Suzette's on different
musicians dossier da fall of this
sharing can he now hard to get through
convivial English only bellossom mission
begins in genre yawn instead the Green
Deal moose Island Ferran Gaveston local
and uncouth financier began our vision
is that van be a heart i nan Sri some
tomorrow patient Green Deal fab hidden
you mr. McGee lignite Knudsen hormones
were under stringent sue for charity it
cites life wound Stephane crib bumpers
in provides a fairly Schnurr information
gets at Sparta Naga mines I'm hundred
and amid kind of a yawn
keine stat on kind of sort plight leave
a France at IRA dear that's all stanky
dear guns had shaken hands I'll switch
to English immediately first of all we
have two reasons to be cheerful today
first of all congratulations on 25 years
of excellent work
for all of you but in particular I want
to congratulate and warmly thank your
president for a job extremely well done
in the last two and a half years without
exaggeration I could say that the
cooperation between our two institutions
has been intensified and has been
focused on those issues which are of
particular importance both to the
European Commission and to the committee
of the regions and especially
to our citizens in the regions and in
the cities
karolides has been extremely important
in organizing all the citizens dialogues
you've done I think 140 over the last
two and a half years and he has been a
driving force of the task force on
subsidiarity with very concrete results
which were supported by the mayor's
taking part in this and the
representatives of the regions I think
this regional hubs pilot project could
be extremely valuable also for the
future of how regions are directly
involved in EU
lawmaking and decision-making the
committee in my view has a huge role to
play in all the in the fundamental
transformation of our society which is
going to happen in the next generation
you know whether we take control of this
or whether we just let it happen there
is going to be a transformation and I
think we are placed before a fundamental
choice do we organize this do we take
control of this on behalf of our
citizens at all levels of government
because if you look at the
transformation that's happening both in
terms of the fourth Industrial
Revolution and all the consequences of
the information society and the
challenge we have on on climate change
all levels of governments will have to
play their role if we want to succeed in
being able to shape our collective
future this is no longer something that
can be done by national governments
alone we need global governance on this
we need the European Union to lead on
this but it will amount to nothing
whatsoever if it is not borne by
concrete measures at a local and
regional level just think of things like
public transport that needs to be
made emissions 3 think about how we need
to treat waste think about how we need
to put SMEs in a position to be able to
be part of the new economy think about
all the changes that we need to bring
about to look after our biodiversity
think about how we're going to
collectively make sure that we isolate
existing buildings that we build new
buildings along the norms that will help
protect a natural environment and and be
sustainable think about the way we need
to green our cities and we need to have
a huge program of reforestation across
all of our regions we need every single
one of you in every member state to be
an integral part of this for us to
succeed and we need also to make sure
that we take the right decisions at the
right level to make this happen
Gallants you were also a very important
contributor to the success of the
covenant of mayors and I think you
you're adopting also an opinion on the
covenant today which i think is
extremely important one of my dreams is
to create a cooperation of of mayors of
cities across the European Union cities
you want to be parts of this network and
just imagine I'm just giving you a
couple of ideas we could work on
just imagine mayors of cities would
agree that we need to green our public
transport and make it emissions free
just imagine then you could organize
this learn from each other and organize
this in a much larger scale because I
see in many cities now procurement going
on for for instance electric buses and
then you talk about relatively modest
numbers 100 buses 200 buses but just
imagine you could collectively organize
this and then procure five thousand
buses six thousand buses it's a
completely different proposition and
it's also a completely different
proposition to
the automotive industry that would be
much more interested if those are the
numbers we are talking about just one
example where I believe this big shift
can happen if we organize it well there
is one point I wanted to insist upon
because it is going to affect all of us
in all the discussions I have on the
Green Deal I'll come to that in a moment
and all the discussions I have on the
Green Deal I always get this yes but can
we afford it because we all know that if
we want this transformation to happen we
will need Yalie investments of hundreds
of billions of euros yearly in
investments and people have been saying
where are we going to get their money
etc etc I'm not too worried about that
but if we have this discussion I would
also like people to understand that
there's also huge cost of non action
climate change is not going to stop
simply because we say it should stop it
won't the digital revolution will not
stop at Europe's door simply because we
say it should stop it won't it's
happening everywhere and we can't afford
to lag behind and if we combine the two
and we get organized at all levels of
government we could shape this in a way
that protects our values and looks after
the interests of our citizens it's a bit
you know along the lines of the famous
discussion tank ad had in the gato Pardo
when he was asked by his father why are
you doing this I want things to stay the
same things to stay the same well if the
climate crisis and the fourth Industrial
Revolution has taught me anything it is
that if we want things to stay the same
as tank AD says everything should change
so if we want our values to be
consistent if we want social justice to
be consistent if we want to leave no one
behind in this transformation we will
have to embrace the reality of the
transformation and shape it and for that
we will need everyone now our idea is to
and this will be a discussion in the
European Council later this month our
idea is to have all Member States commit
to being kalaiy Manute role as the first
climate neutral countenance by 2050 now
if we could commit to that we could then
start by counting back from 2050 to
today and see what needs to be done
between now and 2050 to get to that
point and this is I think it quite a
revolutionary approach traditionally we
would say we need to adapt we need to
change and we will take incremental
steps to go forward now we turned it
around and we say the end goal is
climate neutrality by 2050 so then what
do we need to do by 2030 by 2040 to get
there and why 2050 well I think that you
know human experience shows that any
Industrial Revolution any major shift in
society takes a generation and takes one
at least mostly two cycles of investment
well this is exactly what we're talking
about if we can get the legislation in
place in the next five years then there
are 25 years of a generation left to get
it all implemented and to get where we
need to be that is in my view the
rationale for this now I'm saying this
against the background of a lot of bad
news
I PCC analyses the more science advances
on the analysis of where we are the more
alarming the results are so we have we
are close to a number of tipping points
in the natural development what does
that mean that means that if we go
beyond the tipping points and certain
developments such as the disappearance
of ice in Greenland or what's happening
in the oceans in terms of temperature
shifts or current shift etc some of
these developments will then no longer
be under our control or influence and
will just cascade into other
developments which will bear serious
consequences for all of us to avoid
those tipping points from happening we
have to commit to do everything we can
to make sure that by 2050 the
temperature has not risen above 1.5
degrees this is of very very big
importance to make this happen and so
the bad news is if we don't act very
quickly it's not going to happen in
other bad news we got this week was in
the report of the European environmental
agency where it shows very clearly that
all our member states are lagging behind
what we promised to do before so we have
a backlog and we're lagging behind we're
not doing what we've agreed so that's
the bad news the good news is it can be
done it is not impossible from a
technological point of view we still
need to invest massively in a lot of
technologies but it can be done secondly
it can be financed I mean I said earlier
hundreds of billions of investment every
year but the results of those
investments are extremely good in the
projections because that would make
Europe the first continent to embrace
not just the climate issue but also the
new economy and it would you know lead
to increased growth and increase amount
of jobs and by the way capital today is
not not very expensive and not using
capital is more expensive than using it
even with moderate risks involved but
you would need public action to make it
happen and to bring it again so if it's
not a technological challenge per se if
it's not a financial challenge but say
what's the problem well the problem is
that we need to get this organized
governance is the real challenge here
you know we are standing on once border
of a river which is when will you look
at it it's it's quite daunting and
and scary and we all know we need to go
to the other side we need to cross that
river so fear of crossing the river is
the only thing that's pretend preventing
us from getting to the other side and to
do that I think we as politicians all
have a collective responsibility to take
our societies to where we need to go but
not in a traditional I would say
paternalistic way it has to be a process
that includes the participation of our
citizens that's why the committee of the
region's at the end of the day is so
extremely important the Green Deal we
will launch the communication on the
Green Deal we will launch next week will
have this at its core this is how the
Commission thinks we would need to act
in leading up to 2050 but we are open to
listen to your contributions and we want
you to be part of it because otherwise
it will not happen and crucially we can
leave no one behind because the risk of
this like in any industrial revolution
like in any major paradigm shift the
risk is always that you have a
relatively small group of people who
will come out of this as big big winners
and you have a big big group of people
who will lose that is what happens in an
industrial revolution if it is not
governed by democratic means I fear so
we need to get this organized at all
levels to make sure that everybody comes
along and to make sure that people are
now today are afraid that this is going
to cost them their jobs and that they
can't pay for the isolation of their
houses that their energy prices are
going to go up etc that people know that
what we're doing is something they can
also profit from that's why in our plans
we will have to have a couple of very
concrete proposals objectives that we
could share with people for instance
I'll give you two examples and then I'll
finish for instance I believe we need a
massive massive program of reforestation
and I believe this is something that can
be worked on with you to make sure not
just that we plant trees everywhere but
also that because of climate change
already many of our forests are
suffering and the changes in those
forests should be addressed by measures
that will make these forests more
vibrant again in the same vein we
absolutely need to make a priority of
greening our cities you know in many of
our member states the one issue that is
very topical for citizens is air quality
more than 400,000 people in Europe every
year die prematurely because of bad air
quality and it's getting worse and we
need to take measures in our cities to
make that better so on transportation on
waste management but also on greening of
the cities greening cities will create
carbon sinks so the air quality goes up
and will also lead to especially the
Mediterranean area to lower temperatures
in the cities which is something we
desperately need as well so that's one
example the other example I want to
briefly give you is that when we say to
pee people fear that their energy prices
will rise incredibly if we make this
shift also because as you know many
member states there were massive
subsidies of fossil fuels over
generations so what we could propose to
citizens and to collective organizations
isolate their homes create sustainable
energy for those homes without
increasing the bill and over time
decreasing the bill very often people
want to make that separate they just
can't finance it they don't have the 15
or 20 thousand euros ready to do it so
we need to get that organized and
smaller medium-sized enterprises this is
about millions of jobs small and medium
sized enterprises will have to do the
work but they can't refinance at either
so we'll need to give them the tools to
go to citizens and say we'll isolate
your house we will put solar panels on
your roof or we will put a heat pump in
it the investment is huge you don't need
to pay now you
sign a contract you continue to pay
exactly the same price for energy as you
do now and over next number of years you
will have paid it off and then it's
yours
these are the sort of schemes that will
get people to tag on to what is a
massive change in our society right I
think I limit myself to that I hope with
my examples and with what I've said I
have made clear that we can't do this
without you and that your role in this
will be crucial if we want to make it
happen and if we want to assure that
nobody is left behind
thank you very much guys NetZero people
said and prediction people said
communication I'm a mod for this is if
River is your degree model mode he met
Nora Dunn with Apple respective more pop
top of all day group politic I represent
all the journey politician Yano to
premier vice president
yeah Priscilla Monsieur macula a premium
Akula shooting moments report on
covering for a Primavera Bonilla Victor
tapas community to engage readers
redetermination deserve Pascal
recommends imagine a key Accord that
so pre studied on the parole another
colleague Lamas the executi vice
president best france i speaking English
because I'm not only speaking as a mayor
of Saddam and not only as representative
of the EPP year delegation but I'm also
the chair of the environmental
Commission of the committee of the
regions and thank you very much for your
intervention and after listening to us
your partners in delivering the Green
Deal on the ground a presence here in
this in this room let me start with a
small personal story environment and
climate change where my priorities do
remain whole political career
for example skied on one of the most
effective sit
in the Netherlands may you talk about
air pollution we managed with EU support
to considerably improve the air quality
in the Rotterdam region and embarked on
a journey to a gas freeze ski done by
2050 this requires a lot of work at
various levels of governments innovative
approach and huge investment and
Einstein said once you cannot solve our
problem with the same thinking we used
when we created them this is what we
applied is Kodama this is what we
applied in the committee of the regions
and this is what I gladly observe is
happening in the European Union the
Green Deal is supposed to present a
completely new way of thinking and
dealing with climate change
finally sustainability has been placed
at the heart of all the policy making
and based on my local experience I would
like to mention three aspects for Green
Deal to be successful on the ground on
the local and regional level first of
all we need ambition but we have also to
be realistic a cut of 55% of the co2
emissions by 2030 represents a good
compromise we cannot offer burden our
industry and our SMEs with unrealistic
targets but we need to reach the race
through reuse and recycling targets for
news for waste up to 70% and we have to
offer appropriate incentives to business
and consumers as we cannot continue
polluting our planet and wasting
available resources second we need to
ensure policy coherence here I would
like to make a call for the ACE
environment to action program I was
Robert earlier on that subject for the
committee and we advised to to choose
foreign totally another approach make it
to be in line with Green Deal it's an
instrument to realize
the Green Deal and we shoots develop
place-based approaches and area
orientated strategies but based on
specific themes like healthy and
prosperous metropolitan areas vibrant
countryside or attractive coastal areas
the Green Deal shields provide concrete
solutions in line with local needs and
opportunities for example via a green
public procurement and fret we need to
ensure that green do implements the
conclusions of the subsidiarity task
force under your leadership
if you don't apply an active
subsidiarity taking on board all levels
of government do European the National
the region or in the local evil never
succeeds here I strongly ask you to post
push the Member States to properly
consult local and regional authorities
about the National Energy and Climate
plans moreover if he don't build on the
results on the regional hubs we will not
deliver what the citizens expects from
us to help you with his task the
committee's regions will launch a forum
on our own umbrella a forum of local and
regional authorities to cooperate
closely with you regularly bringing you
feedback and suggestions from the ground
good luck with all your tasks and be
reassured that you can count on the
committee of the regions and the local
and regional authorities and see you in
cop 25 in Madrid thank you Cebu cool la
parola met no another colleague Espada's
wrath upon OGS removal Presidente lumber
Acedo monor trabajar con ustedes todo
Sano's
yo vans are antennas de Norma
importancia en este de Botton como
cordon adored mi grupo en esta cuestión
y tambien como alcalde de Sevilla a
Presidente del R ed de Ciudad a paniolo
k lucha cantar cameo climatic comedy
quattro sienta ciudad a quiero Felicia
tar lazy or timmermans porque es uno
whoo yo you moan or
una persona con usted leader a este gran
proceso en el proyecto rope AO y lo es
porque como hemos acusado aqui se puede
decir más Alto pero no se puede decir
mess Claro qual a solo reto 's equal
debe ser el impulse o el estado de animo
que IKEA o meter para este gran proceso
fishes se yo creo que estas una nueva
oportunidad para la una europaea de
leader AR un proceso en el que el propio
proyecto repay Oh se puede legitimate
message unsick Ave sees Omaha passes de
poner en como a todos los a gente que
son que puede ser que pase de hacer a
tatra phone accion socially economica
que regear a nuestro continent a yasser
low edema sri quiere necesaria mint a el
que los territory owes say implicant AC
siva meant a en como yo vara Cabo no es
posible a a coma terran at reform asean
december Ghidorah si no es con la
implication yell compromiso direct o de
los territorio de las autoridades locale
originally en si sentido no en nuestro
papel probe lament a defini de sousa jet
evo Bakar los recursos para llevar lo
acabo pero si si no es nuestro papal
nuestro papel sin to de-escalate a sus
objetivos Nova ser posible que su a
grande Siqueiros estado
okay la revisión de los acuerdo de Paris
a Madrid la próxima semana pueden ser
una realidad C no somos capaci articular
es a govern Anza de forma mucho más
Affectiva util de lo que hace ahora
hemos hecho fundamental meant a por el
papel de nuestra autores locale a
regional en si sentido a cuando habla
Mo's de acción climatic ax y ou Cohen
sido camote trajo más de vente año en
sustainability' y medio ambiente cohen
sido en que es necesario aplicar recurso
chamber she owned a importante en el
sector public Oyen el sector privado
y para o es evident a que da question
skk resolver uno los recursos lo recurso
tennis a recursos adicional a poor part
a la una europea sobre esta cuestión
creo que no debe ver de soutien
lo recurso hora mismo que siempre anga
política sosial a ha política de cone
sunray cosas que sigue siendo n
presentable henry pro europeo pero
pollito dell new Rindell tiene que tener
recurso propios para poder conseguir
Ojeda boson vicio so como lo que c'est
plant e'en en si sentido creo también
queremos poder utilize our mejor lo
recurso de la semaine estación en este
caso local señora mismo Tonelli Pongo
les implode upon y las actually
políticas de glibly oppress OOP oh sorry
de l'année or Opia loss actually
Siqueiros impeding a la minute a co
local una ciudad como la mia poder
invert Irma's ontraport a public o poder
invert Irma's an rehabilitation
energetic adición yes Tracy incoherent a
con la finally da de si lo so jet Evo de
la una mujer Opia yellow so jet Evo de
mi país de espana poor tanto tenemos que
ser capaz de rebus are también es a
políticas europaeus para ser coherent a
con la mimma política or Opia con la
caída fini mojitos objetivo zambisi o's
Uribe Moses air load EMA en si am Beto
en el que mejor are Lago burn our salmon
tener la coordination entrap minute
ratio nays desde la governance o dopiest
indominus a co local no yeba
probablemente aqui estación nueva
política commune de la una mujer Opia se
que lo que digo es muy am busy Oso pero
creo que leader are este proyecto desde
la numero Perry quiere tener el turida
tambien a la hora de sousa jet Evo
llevar lo hago con los itami mo y por
tanto saludo sin duda
su leader Roscoe yet pero de su
capacidad de negotiation tambien para
conseguir que esto recurso necesario
para estar an finally razandrich Usos
adicional a que podamos llegar a los
rosette evo Mucha Gracia bono Diaz merci
beaucoup la Pavoni Carlos Anguilla
moon or deus a todos para comenzar
quiere hacer el poder estar aqui en
estas SEO sobre el Green Deal
if illicit re desser Mucha suerte Lenovo
Kibo comisarios de la comisión europea
yo especialmente al cine
misrepresentative a man's rescue
charles's problemas de Benghazi hablar
de un problema grab a la near lo pea Eva
Cassidy Thanos intentando save and onl
carbon como Fuente de energía hace Uno's
años en dos mil Diez público logician
del consejo dos mil Diez bara siete Ocho
siete que la practica Alka Senado
l'opéra de las tres Ian de carbón
la casa de la totally das de las niñas
Demi Pais Arianna Fitch auto-pay el
treinta y uno Diciembre de los MIDI sto
Cho el final del año pasado antes de
fetches an sarado ya muchas - econia say
Ciaran tambien las entradas term
eléctricas caiman Kabam para la energía
ma region Castilla Y Leon estamos a
punto de acabar con las semanas de
cerdos residentes del carbón ya casino
contaminate
say cholo europa korea ora desde la
neo-noir Opia erika bar definitivamente
con las Misiones de cerdos
se esta hablando en fondo justo de
transition para regions Carboniferous un
fondo para region are la economía de NOS
tunas kayvyun a través del carbón forma
de vida al carbon say oh no Meah dependi
ah del carbón
dependence casos nosotros estamos
sufriendo ya los problemas de desaad
utilize our carbon hemos prado la
sección de carbon sufi muslim gravis
consecuencias altas tosses des empleo
destroy sein de la economía problemas de
gestion de energía para de población a
Las Tunas monedas chasey no sushi onaka
erin prácticamente despo ghada's porque
el carbon era su forma de vida nosotros
NOS prada llama el carbon seen a ver una
alternativa economica y por ellos - free
Mo's krebs problemas con amigos esto SI
a lays very most hecho lo q dopa quería
por ESO cuando vas sa blonde Tia che
luego fondo transition who stopped a
region s Carboniferous saya solo para
vionnet's case against say no carbon Oh
contaminant Oh nos parece muy justo no
SE debe crear un fondo all vidonne doe a
los que estan sufriendo las
consecuencias v al Bob and Ray del
carbón
como el SP do
los problemas en la economía aparecen
despues de banda gnarly Carboni si just
transition found s a fondo a decision
justo
viva la palabra transition in su nombre
porque el fondo no debe ser por tener
Mina's C no parent r la transition a Co
no muy loco no mokou mi ratio no Yo no
de vionnet's es a transition you know
estar a lazada si necesita or sentiment
a Pruett repartee si fondo decision
justo
yebin su nombre la palabra justo justo
de justicia y para que se fondo saya
realmente justo no puede abandonado OS
nor are a los que and asado de
contaminate poori como se antes el / are
las niñas SE puede ver hecho en un dia
pero la economía de nuestras tunis
maneras a Corrado Destro's ah de se nos
a pony ayuda de fondos economicus
seguirá destrosa durante las próximas de
cada siglos muchas gracias
[Applause]
stapes come mr. Timmons mounts I am a
regional minister off the province of
Renta in the northern Netherlands
what is the first heart in Feli in
Europe to receive a European Commission
subsidy for its per project called
heaven together with public-private the
co-financing we will infest 90 million
euros in developing a fully functioning
green hydrogen chain as part of creating
a zero emission future for our citizens
s business being a member of this
committee has taught me however that not
all EU regions have the means to be as
ambitious in their action plans as denta
many of them are still dependent on
fossil fuels not because they want to
but because they inherited their energy
mix from the Soviet times the primary
concern is the stability of the system
and energy prices therefore in the EGR
group we believe that in order to reach
our goals we need to keep an open mind
about different technologies and energy
sources not all of our region's
can progress at the same pace because
the starting point of investing in clean
energy is not the same the European
Commission
should not have a one-size-fits-all
approach to watch all countries and
regions climate change is one of the
great challenges humanity has ever faced
we do need a new comprehensive and
responsible framework the goals we want
to achieve must take into account the
concerns of business
she's communities and workers it is
important that the Green Deal will be
based on detailed territorial impact
assessments and concrete financing plans
that will leave no region behind
although my personal ambition for the
northern Netherlands I'm aware that many
of my fellow issue our members are
afraid that their communities were
suffer from high energy bills and many
businesses will be forced to relocate
outside EU borders when climate change
targets increase for the reason they are
skeptical about today's resolution but
finally you spoke about the Commission's
plan on housing or innovation that is
the type of support that many
communities expect from the Commission
cutting greenhouse gas in fest investing
into houses and create new jobs and
reduce an additional demoted or less
daunting quality longjumeau de passing
maxi beaucoup the Parliament not the
collective one after commissaries
basically has and the chromatin of T V
of the Train network that climate was a
restriction developed the global
mountain and who oak here and this group
is in selling over his edema of the
agenda when Phil was broken the debate
ate stomping to where the engine omen
spits with the head and green deals with
the Halong sales mark master Cola has
the Tate is in the data coma for
concrete oxy
you repeat oxy we will trade the oxy
burners Kenneth in selling in politic it
made the veldt and was on the naming at
all sector
hundun in our constant and some
different to allocate opening them who
do that for all need a buffer
Ruth drag and select on the boat and
will to who was asleep the savers the
Morgan op appeal firm at the best valve
and availeth little bar saying we're
happy were well not our dues Amma really
Caesar talk ambition symmetry focusing
abduction but also statement in Europa
once on the nameless hub on expertise
and also creativity aids that owns in
Zack top university take the rows of red
tongue and induce am in the steering's
plum that on so a labor market van
Europa and was the best practical at the
restaurant evaded expert Aaron best
million temperaments by hoping that the
Green Deal initiative need sir interlude
Salim
thus the AutoZone buttons are insane and
both now hysterical linked to secure map
and in there his own reflect error and
American hot and the Tennessee capacity
trans ratios season and Hemington the
return address that were dealing the
whole reduced telling cost ever since I
was in and at the international
flexibility to lads button the well
including it American the but Albert hey
Tandy seduced any one of the burners and
the concurrency position on the naming
and did it all worth Lord and after all
need work for heating that owns a
repeater reuse still a him enters in the
electrical current as well American not
when were talking head and understanding
of this later mater crucial is thank you
merci beaucoup a bit nicer than the
power Martina and grace dear president
Lambert's be a vice president's in my
months dear members of the European
Committee of the regions I am my Tina
Greek I was 18 years old when I was
elected to represent my local council in
or me a community and a small about
big-hearted island in the middle of
Europe Malta and now I am here today in
Brussels to represent all my fellow
young elected politicians
who come from all over Europe thanks to
the COI through exchange together our
views experiences and expectations on
how to accelerate climate action locally
young people are demonstrating around
the world for climate justice we agree
with them that we have to go from
talking to acting it is a matter of
political will we have this political
will we are ready to act and lead by
example do you have the political will
will you help us in order to take
further action we need further legal
financial and political support from the
European Union to have a bigger impact
for the last few days
young elected European politicians have
come together across political and
national boundaries
we have United on a climate action
footprint documents you france in my
months you you and you as members of the
European Committee of the regions
sitting in these chairs you need to
support us now we have to jumpstart
actions and scale up solutions now
actions speak louder than words we ask
you to boost a green and circular
economy focus on social transition via
green education boost the share and
reuse economy ensure a green and just
taxation policy supports local cheaper
accessible and cleaner public
transportation reduce bureaucracy and
simplify regulations invest more in
sustainable building renovations you and
I are all part of local communities we
as young leaders work hard in our local
communities to make a livable future for
ourselves and our future children we
unites we come together cross parties
and cross European countries and if I as
a 19 year old can take action and if I
can stand up here today to make our
voice head so can you help us succeed
faster as we take action let's do this
now thank you
Matt Seeber pupuce at labahn at the Vasa
was a future with every push the
photograph Cotulla rest the last year
merci beaucoup
even not enough of all are not whispers
adore Marku mccoullough our voice ah ha
ha Lorenzen akin katate dori right
oh ma la la is he miracle and a terminal
and a Noster determine ambi theatres own
tortillas Palio korekiyo malik we meet
operational muster so vamoose
err Aleta demonic save est Ortolan Tammy
far away of the optimum and salinity
Oh milady la la la quwata mercy o attack
in SE mere kya Norstar Milan Tourette
Maharaj oratory la savate okuni Enomoto
so yo cons is Marty bumpy comparison so
famous yeah tan meet Arvid see Marella
Kavya kaboom karela Kavya Alouette
Michiel Tavano robusta on Kobol a new
stage two and two locks knock IPL
turmoil Muslim Oh mark upon Cain es para
esta cosa Helsing in pack up on Keala
wet Tamela mesito to net Sabu tamaño
Yukon Quest Ivanka he took centavo it
that is crikey Tomas decussate semester
Kapoeta your coccyx you meta coccyx you
madhavi's his rail encode and while you
could have water passed away repeat
Isola also edit but meeting a massive
Odetta a pontoon immersed island
yeah but a pea Timmerman silly hollow as
ISA mallalieu ovata Maiden Helsing in
law and aloe and car in Criminal Code
and Khun na new station Oh element
meeting om a healing arrow trolley
coccyx you meant a column activity' be
easy
say you like our table our alma mater or
team s in annoying Nelly equipment a
real
Satomi empirical data varicose Toyota iQ
what you total tamasa but mainland and I
also it about at the contain a Michael
isn't a zone time MP do him my sister
Corita console is wealthier than yes in
vaulted anomia oh he'll Mia on how a
woman I admit emit a missing console i
stinking sorry tristan certain European
tenure a Justin Julio pastry and Kohli
and hike in consequence Matata ultimatum
and
intima Cunha an emotion tabatin
submission to Allah model list yeah
you're so painting written later saloon
color interest atomic will take the old
invoice into all her movements
formalizing a see Ozzy and Aunty and
console so it Tom on it me tonight today
latter Evita mitten Kanpur and cool did
France Timmerman see that ticket Ally
source
civil and commercial East until master
Motomu destroy mean emit a metamer
nearest element even Milan
arena my Zanja V isomer chaos on shurima
I read axiom you can Enochian
basic atonement a median element law to
total Assad on vivax avoid metal people
are Somali she was made see to exist
it's a kill or a theater man he talked
apollyon Kuno an instant LMS annually
SATA to what the puta your Turkish robot
Perseus Allah peace because what vaneeta
I mean coastal one tones here like rank
mutiny Cosmo between Kiev I could have a
Tillman law to release 870 the present
the pintle as Thomas warmest on mates
hello male on the man I have P recycle
reduce it cancel I spoke I musta
validate the vana yeah so peak with
parent of Avila's en aton I'm a chorus
tantino Zeta ki O rahi pyar Vinick on
Vera an alluring Committee on wall to
spoon tamadre Lisa business in a woman
in Minnesota mallet III router Tait
Sivan so mr. Lane and katana made and
it's a nice curve and Hilton a woman
Aveda me it's a nice favorite
Satoru Mehta an activist and the
Ilham estimate Austin Modoc centavo
Tarasov optimises he does destiny merci
beaucoup met Nova setup of all masucci
moments pou kill Piscopo novel remark a
suggestion thank you very much
sadly I've run out of time so I'll try
and be as brief as I can you know a bit
provocative imagine some astronomers
would discover in a galaxy far far away
a comet that is heading to earth and if
we do nothing it will hit Earth in 30
years time and then we would say yeah we
need to do something but hmm should be
affecting our business too much we need
to change a couple of things but not too
much we've had calls for so long let's
keep it awhile we are in a climate
emergency it's not just nice to do we
need to do it so please keep that in
mind when you say it should not be too
disruptive for businesses businesses
need to adapt and by the way most
businesses absolutely understand this I
think the sense of urgency especially in
big business is higher than in politics
frankly so let's keep this in mind when
we say well it we need to be realistic
realistic is that we have a climate
crisis that's realistic realistic is
that if we don't belong to the early
adaptors the pace will be dictated by
other continents and we can just follow
what they do instead of being masters of
our own destiny that is realistic but of
course in this process we need to look
at our existing rules and weather and
our existing policies and whether they
are still fit for purpose in the
framework of this challenge and they're
I would say the just transition fund is
important but it's only part of a much
larger just transition mechanism because
we have to reorient all
policies towards helping our regions or
cities our member states to adapt and to
make sure that we can embrace the
opportunities these two fundamental
developments will offer and this will
differ from region to region in many
parts of the Mediterranean regions we
will have to do a lot of work on climate
adaptation desertification is a huge
challenge the lack of water one day and
being flooded the other day is a huge
challenge
it's Spain the phenomenon called gota
Fria was something that happened every
50 years now it's happening almost every
year and who knows even more than once a
year this has huge implications for our
adaptation efforts but this offers also
huge opportunity for businesses at the
same time in Central and Eastern Europe
the air quality in cities is dismal and
is there anyone in this room who finds
it acceptable that our children grow up
in air that is so bad that this is
impeding their growth and making them
sick no no and we can't change that but
if these regions can't do it on their
own
that just transition fund and other
means should be put at their disposal to
make it happen I myself am from a coal
region the last coal mine in our region
was closed 50 years ago and still today
you know and my hometown used to be
among the 2/3 richest cities in the
Netherlands and for the last 40 years my
hometown has been between the three or
four poorest cities in the Netherlands
so I know that if you don't do this
right whole region's will lose out and
this cannot happen so that's where we
need and that's why also we had a long
conversation last night with the et you
see to make sure that we leave no one
behind it that we have specific programs
for the specific situations and specific
regions and the coal regions will need
that but just imagine just think for
five minutes which fundamental
the automotive industry is going to go
through in the next decade just think
for five minutes what's going to happen
to the steel industry where we need to
make steel factories use hydrogen as
energy instead of coal and other fossil
fuels just imagine what the level of
investment needs to be and then yes we
will also have to look at state aid
rules are they still fit for this we
will have to look at how we unleash the
investment potential of public and
private potential investors how we help
banks move towards a green investment
policy which some are doing and I
particularly want to salute the European
Investment Bank that is going very
quickly in that direction so my message
to you is never ever underestimate the
huge huge transformational situation we
are in and it might you know give you
some comforts to think we can continue
just you know tweaking a bit changing a
bit here nice plan there no this is a
paradigm shift and the sooner everybody
understands list the sooner we can take
the right measures to get where we need
to be and I retain a huge level I'm
realistic about the challenge but I'm
optimistic about the opportunity we have
to use that challenge to set Europe on a
path which will make us the leaders in
the world in the new economy and to
create a situation where we live in
balance with our natural environment if
we continue to live like this we will
need four earths we only have one so we
need to rebalance that and we can do
that we need to create circular economy
we've made the first moves in that
direction it's working very well we need
to decarbonize our transport system we
need to decarbonize our energy system we
need to create Europe wide grids you
know because renewable energy is paying
for itself now it doesn't need any
subsidies anymore it's paying for itself
it's cheaper the problem is we don't
have the grids to bring it everywhere
and the problem is we don't have the
ways of of transposing one form of
energy
in another form of energy so we have to
invest in all these things but if we do
that we have the collective capacity to
do it but you all need to be on board
for this to happen and I count on your
support thank you very much mr.
president
[Applause]
merci beaucoup what the country wish I
would be successful with the travail a
poor family my oven and the oven eeeh